the women in this universe have kind of
changed it G right here oh my god
are you I don't I like that title like
in theory but then like in practice okay
are you on the OG tax chain I heard that
there's original six text chain oh my
god it's so it's brute I have to
actually take myself off of it time and
again I'm just like has been removed
from the conversation or whatever I'm
just like you guys are crazy it's so
much
who's crazy on the text chain they're
all it's a combination it's like a bad
gene reaction that happens words it's
wrong people are long you're sick
there's there's thank God that like
women have now I mean everybody's happy
but oh yeah it reflects what's going on
in the zeitgeist I'm like think these
people have saved me from like a
testosterone fueled like it's like a
fresh haircut
thank God so you're happy to see the
ladies you're like oh yeah we get our
own trailer like I'm into decorating
before things okay I don't think we need
to go together in this separate way more
civilized bathroom stays cleaner yeah
did I what's it like being a part of
this group it's amazing it's fantastic I
mean you know we started off you know
with Lokhande and we were building this
little world together and you know we
all just came we were all new to the to
the universe and and we were just
working together and and you know we had
of course they also make more there and
then we had Ryan but it was just this
one this one world we were creating and
making sure we could deliver and with
all of its you know full kaleidoscope of
color and and reality and truth and then
we got to like step onto the set of
infinity war well actually they came to
a Content right but you know tent of the
like you know where they you know place
the actors we open it up and just to see
like these The Avengers like sitting
there next to us and
just go home scream together I mean this
is like when you realize oh my god we
are in a universe this is this we're all
like one thing now and that was that was
an amazing mind trip in an enhanced way
there's bananas on yeah okay what can
you tell us if any cuz I've asked
everybody what is the one thing you can
tell us about the movie um the one thing
I can tell you about the movie is that
you know I have sort of like I always
fall back and describe this is like a
beautiful Valentine to the fans and to
the franchise's and you know from what
I've seen which is not a lot but like
what I experienced on set you know it is
like we have all of us all of us actors
all of our crew our directors all of
Marvel of like poured their blood sweat
and tears into this phone and I think it
will just literally be like it hopefully
will deliver what happens if you give
away a Marvel secret it's kind of like
the exactly No yeah
is it scary are you like please let this
movie just hit the theater so we can
talk about it I mean such a relief I
just cannot wait till the end credits
roll and then I can just like oh my god
is there a scene I don't know but I
don't know either as weeks wait till
after that ah did you just tell us
something I didn't literally don't know
I also heard that there are that people
had faked scenes dummy scenes that there
were scenes that you were doing there
weren't real but they were just to throw
people off what
really that's like a whirl of waste of
time
I'm calling the line producer I'm just
saying I'm hearing that's a waste of
dollars right there
somebody threw that out there I think
that was just a disgruntled actor that
was like I just did that scene and now
you're cutting it actor right there how
did you know yeah you're right but it
was part it was right you're right how
does it how does it how do you handle
being in this part of this Wakonda
revolution how is it in your life like
it kind of like people lost their minds
you know really really was the last time
folks came to a theater dressed
folks listen amazing it was amazing we
could never have anticipated that you
know we really just came together to you
know create this thing we did you know I
started with saying with you know doing
this it was a heart and soul pouring in
because we had never seen anything like
what we were getting to do before and we
had a hunger to see it and and you know
the world obviously had it had an hunger
for this sort of representation as well
and this sort of storytelling and you
know Ryan was so brilliant at bringing
together very personal stories in a very
epic way and so you know seeing how it
riveted across the Diaspora because the
community and Lapita were in Nigeria and
and South Africa right as it was opening
and then a few months after and of
course here and in London and seeing how
it just that reverberation across the -
poor is like something I don't know if
I've seen in my lifetime and and that
coming together of the dice for is
something that I just I really hope
continues to happen because there's so
much obvious clear power in it yeah so
what's the workouts like because you
have Hemsworth on one side you know you
know you have like these do
okay what he does I'd love to know just
you know I mean I'm not gonna do it but
just go I don't know I think he eats a
lot of like chicken like I've seen in me
a lot of chicken I don't know for like
10 years
those chicken kids don't cuz all really
like that's what's gonna be left like
after the apocalypse is just chicken
bones that's how much chicken meat I'm
sorry I went off on like a whole up yeah
are the workouts I know I tried to never
be like I'm like I was in like a three
weeks to the cat suit like I like to
keep that kind of maintenance yeah
that's my maintenance right there cuz
once you go past three weeks
it just it gets too hard oh you just
can't bring it back after that point
you're like forget it I give in yeah but
it's regular I like to keep up my
fitness it's part of my mental health
it's the only time I get to not focus on
life stuff I get to dress like zone out
and get it all out at the gym so I like
to keep me Tina good you know
steady balances three weeks out and
three weeks out yeah I don't feel good
anyway you know you want to feel its
strong strong yeah and healthy ish as
much as you could hope you know I'm not
gonna deny myself the fries all the time
do this your last chance you sure
there's not a secret you want to tell me
I mean I got was like what is it what is
it